we have a voicemail number you can call
anytime here is a call at 2192 David P
about the Spanish Channel Dave it's Alan
from Jersey I appreciate stand every
single day you keep promoting the
Spanish channel on the English Channel
well I didn't promote it today
I'm not interested in Spanish I don't
speak more than a couple words in
Spanish I don't want Spanish stop
promoting the Spanish Channel but more
importantly than that anybody that's
listening to the English Channel can
speak English so they don't need to go
to the Spanish Channel because they
already know English
it's like 18 it's like drive through
ATMs that have rail you know we say oh
that's great you know people who are
blind can use brow at the ATM but what
blind person is going to drive up to the
ATM okay beautiful analogy except it
doesn't really work so let me just
explain something here I understand you
like I I'm not blind to the reality
that if you're listening to this show in
English you probably speak English great
okay fantastic that being said lots of
people know others
who don't have the English language
capacity to take this type of content in
English but they do in Spanish and so I
have this huge platform that I've spent
time building and many of you know
people who would like a Spanish version
of the show that's why I say hey we make
a lot of this show now available in
Spanish for people who prefer that and
so for example if you are a 22 year old
whose parents immigrated to the U.S and
they speak conversational English but
would rather political content in
Spanish you can tell them hey the David
Pacman show that I listen to is
available in Spanish for you guys
um so I I don't know if you know that
that's more or less the explanation all
right we've got a great bonus show for
you today producer Pat is back we will
find out what he was up to
we will talk about the impact of the
fact that police departments were not
defunded but some have chosen to
downsize why what's going on we will
discuss Kevin McCarthy is telling
Americans don't protest if Trump is
arrested does Kevin McCarthy have the
right idea and lastly California has
entered a contract to make its own
insulin and to make it affordable we
will talk about how this will work
whether it will work and so much more on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad join me my friends let's make
money on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and don't worry we will
be back tomorrow with a new show you'd
better believe it